I don't understand what EA thinking they
green light like a dead space remake but
they won't give an original Ip in the
TitanFall Universe like I love the
remake of Dead Space it's cool but it's
just like people would have lost their
minds
I think they would have oh the other
side it could be it could be us capping
for something we love right
here the thing is the thing is is I
don't I think people would lose their
mind because if it's respawn let me put
it that response making it okay 81 hours
making it they showed us Apex Legends
Titanfall and they showed us Jedi fall
in order and Survivor there's no way
people ain't hyping this game oh man
okay okay I got it so I understand all
right let me real quick understand so I
understand they're thinking about well
we're gonna do it we're gonna do it as
part of Apex because Apex is is